wasn't that ending amazing i will
remember you okay maybe that didn't
happen but holy crap there's only one
thing i have to say about loki's final
episode
wow wow wow wow
wow that's right loki has come to an end
or if you're in my timeline
just the end of season one yes not only
has season two been confirmed but this
episode
by far has the biggest implications for
the future of the mcu
and in my mind really is the jump start
for phase 4
even though technically one division
black widow and falcon in the winter
soldier came before it in this video
we'll be taking a deep dive into the
ending
easter eggs you might have missed and
you'll want to stick around for theories
about
season two including where and when
ravona went to back in time
so grab a pack of kablooey and some
delicious roxy wine if you're of age of
course hi-c ecto cooler if you're not
and make sure to like and subscribe
seriously only three percent of you are
subbed because
here we go over the marvel logo you'll
hear
excerpts of various marvel characters as
we travel toward the end of time
falcon black panther ant-man thor steve
rogers captain marvel and loki are just
a few of the characters you'll hear
excerpts from but this slowly changes to
incorporate
real-life figures who have shaped
humanity including neil armstrong alan
watts malala maya angelou and nelson
mandela they even added visions what is
grief if not
love persevering line and it's fitting
we're traveling through space and time
considering the finale's episode title
for all time always which is the time
variance authority slogan we can make
out here
and also what ravona and mobius say to
each other for all time
always at the end of episode 5 loki and
sylvie managed to tap
into the time trash compactor known as
eliath to reach the citadel at the end
of time
they believe that whoever lives here is
manipulating both
time and the tva and for sylvie this is
extremely personal at a young age sylvie
was taken from her timeline by the tva
and narrowly escaped being pruned by
hopping from apocalypse to apocalypse to
avoid detection
loki variants after all are survivors
because loki survive
that's just what we do so it's kind of
no wonder that sylvie eventually kills
he who remains
we'll get to him in a bit inside the
citadel they're greeted by miss minutes
who's been he who remains henchmen from
the start you might be wondering why i
haven't referenced him as
kang at least not yet that's because as
far as we know this
isn't him rather one of his many
variants jonathan magers the actor here
has
been cast as kang in the upcoming
ant-man and the boss quantum mania
yet he's credited as he who remains just
like loki had different named variants
of himself
so too will he who remains and one of
those will be
kang miss minutes tells them he who
remains has a proposition a deal which
would allow loki to kill
thanos and acquire the infinity gauntlet
basically giving him the asgardian
throne and
everything he's ever wanted for sylvie
she can stop
living on the run and experience quote a
lifetime of happy memories i also just
enjoyed the production design of the
citadel with these clock-faced statues
and gears as if the citadel is some sort
of machine
and there's something to be said for
that even the citadel's tower looks like
it's one of the tva's batons
i might also be reading too much into
this but in this room there are four
time keeper statues with one of them
being smashed
did this just happen over time or did he
who remains have a drunken bender and
knock it over
loki believes this proposal is fiction
we write our own destiny now
and destiny has been a central theme of
loki
are we bound to fate or do we have free
will
according to the tva there is no such
thing as free will there is
but one path and we must follow it but
loki being the god of mischief that he
is
doesn't believe that i live within
whatever path i choose
my choices are my own he believes that
he's in control of his own
destiny and control ties into what makes
loki tick
why he is who he is he tells mobius he
hurts people around him because
it's the cruel elaborate trick conjured
by the weak to inspire fear
the desperate play for control by
causing chaos
loki gains control and this control can
only be maintained through hurting those
close to him
but if loki is really going to change
he'll need to learn how to let go
and trust others not big on trust are
you
trust is for children and dogs this is
where sylvie comes in
if they're going to defeat the man at
the end of time they'll need to trust
each other
and since they're both variants of each
other they share the same flaw
an unwillingness to trust how do i know
that in the final moments you won't
betray me
as loki tells her and that's not who i
am anymore
the irony here is that it's sylvie who
ends up not trusting
loki breaking his heart in the process
why aren't we saying this the same way
because you can't trust
and i can't be trusted now i'm hesitant
to call sylvie's actions here a betrayal
she was always straight up with loki
that she was gonna
kill whoever was responsible for taking
her away but her unwillingness to hear
loki out and
trust him is the real dagger in loki's
heart
love is a dagger the amazing thing here
is that loki proved he could change
which flies in the face of what classic
loki said in episode 5.
cannot change we're broken
every version of us forever meanwhile
ravona renssler is busy copying tva
files but will later learn that they
have been switched with files that he
who remains
thinks will be more useful but why would
he who remains
do this in the comics ravono was the
daughter of king corellius a ruler in
40th century earth
she eventually met kang the conqueror
and became his lover it's entirely
possible he who remains
knew he was going to die and thus set up
ravona with these documents knowing
she'd end up meeting kang
i think what's great about this
storyline is it sets up two
ravonas against each other the one who's
on king's side and rebecca terminette or
terminae who we see hunter b15 meet at a
ohio high school in 2018.
ravona also takes a quick look at the
markings left by either a whiskey or
coffee glass or at least that's what
they look like to me in episode 4 we see
coasters and glasses used by ravona and
mobius after they celebrate the capture
of loki and sylvie and in episode 2 we
see a coffee cup in the exact same
location these markings were found i
interpret this as a reminder of her
friendship she had with mobius a
friendship she'll accuse mobius of
betraying near the end of the episode
remember that she was the one to kill
him and doesn't yet know he's made it
out of the void
mobius believes everyone should have
free will but as ravonna says
free will only one person gets free will
the one in charge so later on in the
episode when she says she's going in
search of free will what she's
really saying is she's in search for the
one in charge
just another clue that she'll be meeting
up with kang the one in charge in at
least
one of these alternate timelines he who
remains finally introduces himself to
sylvie and loki he wears purple just
like in the comics and this color seems
to be indicative of villains seen in
phase four
like agatha berensimo and even valentina
allegra defontaine
in his confrontation with ravona mobius
takes out a franklin d
roosevelt high school pen we actually
first saw this in
episode 2. mobius says about the pen in
that episode
i don't remember this this must be from
that and unless you keep on the side
when hunter b-15 encounters ravona in
that fdr high school
ravonna doesn't seem to know who they or
the tva
are so it's kind of left up in the air
the extent of these two knowing each
other
or one of the other how did that high
school pen get in tva ravona's
possession
was it a remnant from her past life
before she was taken in by the tva
and her memory wiped or is there
something more here and is there
anything to the fact the high school is
named after wartime u.s
president roosevelt after all the series
seems to be heading to a multiverse war
of course when silvi gets in the
elevator with he who remains she tries
to
kill him but he is equipped with a
circular version of a temp pad allowing
him to quickly teleport out of the way
he'll later explain he knows every move
they're going to make and
program this device ahead of time
accordingly we know he's not bluffing
about this because he'll later show loki
and silvie the transcription of their
dialogue the same kind of thing we saw
in episode 1 when loki first appeared at
the tva
references to the wizard of oz here as
he who remains explains he quote
paved the road loki took to get here he
who remains is the metaphorical man
behind the curtain pulling the strings
we also see this list of equations in
the background here we'll find similar
equations in the end
credits but it all hearkens to he who
remains backstory
of being a brilliant scientist from the
31st century
who discovered multiple universes were
stacked on top of his own
different versions of himself from these
various universes made
contact initially it was peaceful and
they shared their knowledge and
technology but not
every version was pure of heart here
we'll see one variant over the corpses
of others it wasn't until the
weaponization of eliath the entity we
saw in episode 5 that he who remains was
able to
end the multiversal war by controlling
it he could prevent
future branches and timelines from
emerging and create an age of cosmic
harmony his rule he argues has kept the
peace
came to kill the devil i
keep you safe the devil is also
referenced in episode 1
here where he has gold robes gold the
same color that's part of he who remains
costume he who remains also eats an
apple the fruit this serpent used to
tempt eve in the garden of eden
serpents are also referred to as both
dragons and the devil in the book of
revelation
funny since he who remains will later
tell loki that he's a flea on the back
of a dragon
he who remains says they have two
options one kill him and deal with an
infinite amount of devils or two sylvie
and loki could run the tva together and
maintain the timeline but why would he
who remains want to give up control
if we're gonna believe him he simply
says he's old and tired but before they
make a decision he remains senses that
they have crossed the quote
threshold the point at which he no
longer knows what happens
i like to think this is what wanda
experienced while searching the
multiverse in the post-credits of the
wanda vision finale this crossing of the
threshold causes the sacred timeline to
stream
uncontrollably in multiple directions he
who remains says if they do
end up killing him he'll just end up
back there anyway one of his variants
will eventually take control and attempt
to prune the timeline to avoid chaos
but sylvie thinks this is all a lie she
wants to kill him
but loki does not this causes sylvie to
think loki just wants the throne he
tells her he doesn't care about that
i just want you to be okay and then we
get one of the most epic kisses in
recent mcu history followed by
an epic betrayal silva uses he who
remains his device to port loki to a
different
timeline whereas i'll later explain a
rewritten timeline
what i'm really curious about here is if
she knows where she's sending loki or if
it's going someplace
already programmed by he who remains
either way as
sylvie kills he who remains he says see
you soon
that's because one of the variants will
inevitably cross paths with her
and that's the last we see of sylvie in
the finale but it also sets up
great potential for her character in
season 2. she'll have to team up with
loki to put a stop to kang but also
learn that
she too can change and open herself up
to trusting others
loki believes he's back at the same old
tva however when he warns b15 and mobius
that countless versions of a dangerous
variant are coming for them and they
need to prepare they have no idea who he
is
loki has been teleported to a timeline
where it appears
kang rules but how it has to be ravona
he who remains must have known he was
going to die
and this would have created a
multiversal war so he sends ravono with
files that likely will help her in
either convincing
locating or helping kang come into power
in this alternate timeline it isn't
the time keepers who keep order at the
tva it's
kang mobius and b15 don't recognize loki
because the timeline has essentially
been rewritten
and this would also explain how sylvie
teleported loki there she probably just
wanted to port him to the tva but didn't
know it would take him to this rewritten
tva
another big question mark is eliath this
was the entity that allowed for he who
remains to come into power
will it come back into play the other
unknown is this
second ravona who b-15 went back in time
to retreat he
remains mentioned that different
timelines used to battle it out and i
think that's where season 2 is headed
we'll have loki in this kang ruled
timeline while alternate versions of b15
mobius and ravona
a massive counter force in a different
timeline but the biggest question i know
that's on
everyone's mind is will mobius finally
get that jet ski
we'll just have to wait for season 2 to
find out thanks for watching everyone i
want to hear your thoughts and theories
about loki and the mcu below
be sure to like and subscribe and for
more bad takes you can always follow me
on twitter and instagram
at thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you